well hey y'all how you doing we say
y'all down in the South where I'm from I
speak fluent redneck so hopefully you
can understand the brand of English that
I use my name is David Neil I go by
Reverend akan the twitters I try to be
funny sometimes I succeed every now and
again and I am so excited to be here at
the first in DC Minnesota to talk about
electron and to cover you know kind of
the roadmap of what we're gonna do is
we're gonna talk about electron why do
we want to use electron what problems
does it solve why do we even care about
building desktop apps in this mobile
first web first world that we live in
and give you some a crash course on how
to get started and some tips from my
experience so far and this is one of my
favorite photos took this in Chattanooga
Tennessee they win the interstates so I
want to tell you about my story or my
journey into picking up electron and
using it
I've been a.net developer for a long
time I was at the PDC in 2000 when C
sharp and asp.net were announced they
gave every one of us in that conference
a little book called presenting C sharp
and being the nerd that I am I went back
to the hotel that night and read it
cover-to-cover
it wasn't very big but it it like
introduced me to the C sharp language I
fell in love with it and I used it for
many many years
and when the time came that I needed to
create not only some command-line tools
and some desktop applications to help
solve a problem at my company I needed
to be able to allow a you know give some
of my customers who use Mac's
the the ability to also run this
software
and I thought well there's xamarin which
my our mobile team uses and has is
having great success building
cross-platform mobile apps I've heard
that there's a xamarin you know app for
desktop applications I think I'll just
use my mad net skills and create some
desktop apps and I found that yes
through portable class libraries at the
time and you know ma know that you could
create a shared net codebase that you
could leverage on any platform but
that's kind of where the benefits ended
so xamarin Mac does not get the same
amount of love as the iOS and Android
you know tools and native UI is still
extremely hard it's up to you to build
the wind forms or you know WPF or
whatever you're gonna build on Windows
have to use Xcode UI builder to build
the UI for Mac and on Linux god help you
me being a web developer I didn't know
how to do any of those things and you
know my extent of experience building
desktop applications prior to this was
like here's a big gray window with a big
giant button click me and that's it I
don't have really good desktop UI skills
and deployment was really hard because
if you're gonna build you know you it's
kind of easy for for Windows because
there's dotnet is you know exists on
most modern desktops and you can deploy
that but getting mono on other systems
Mac and Linux it's it's not that easy
and at the time this was before
Microsoft acquired xamarin and licensing
was a deal breaker this is not something
I was going to build the sell to our
customers these were just utilities that
our customers get used to solve a
problem and you know
I couldn't justify spending a thousand
dollars a year on a license you know for
just some things that we're gonna make
some folks lives a little bit easier and
so I came away feeling really frustrated
with you know the prospect of having to
learn how to do UI on all these things
and and just not getting that much
benefit so I heard of this thing called
electron and the pros
being that it's HTML CSS and JavaScript
these are things I'm comfortable with
I've been a web developer since the late
90s and you know I can build decent
looking you eyes I can I know how to use
these technologies there's lots of tools
that are available and this sounds like
it's pretty cool electron uses node and
Chrome which is already cross-platform
and it's you know some technologies that
I was interested in along with
JavaScript and it was really awesome so
it's not just and when you're creating
an electron application it's not just
any version of node or you're not you're
not having to depend on the a specific
version of node or chrome on a person's
computer it's bundled into the
application so it's completely
standalone which make brings up
deployment is really really awesome the
cause when you package up an electron
application you're packaging this
version of node this version of Chrome
you're not having to deal with cross
browser you know compatibilities because
you're only targeting chrome you don't
have to deal with older versions of node
or anything like that you're you're
targeting you know a specific
environment making the development a
whole lot simpler and my experience
building electron was a lot more success
you know as I started getting into it it
was you know there were a lot of
problems that were already solved there
were a lot of tools that were available
in the electron framework that just made
the whole experience a whole lot easier
and as I mentioned before since you're
targeting a very specific version of
node
and chrome and the v8 engine the v8
JavaScript engine you can use the latest
and greatest language syntax and
features of es6 and and and beyond and
not have to do any transpiration or
anything like that really really cool so
I'd be remiss not to mention that there
are some drawbacks to building an
electron application and that would be
its HTML CSS and JavaScript if you're
not already a web developer that might
be a bit of a challenge and you know we
all love to bash on JavaScript a little
bit of history of electron it was
created by github for atom the atom
editor and it was formerly called the
atom shell but to reduce you know
misunderstanding of what it's capable of
doing they rebranded it as electron and
it's been active and around since
January of 2013
now 1.0 came out in 2016 and they just
released 2.0 a few days ago and it's got
a lot of nice new features you can have
in-app purchasing on Mac apps and some
other cool things so some of the
features that electron brings to you
that makes building desktop apps so much
easier is there's a you know of course
you got rapid development there's things
like themes you know if you've used an
electron application in the past you may
have you know a lot of them have the
ability to change the look and feel of
the application
well is just CSS right CSS and some
images you can easily add those same
kind of features into your desktop
applications where you can give someone
the ability to create a light or dark
theme or something like that there's all
kinds of native user experience things
that are built-in
there's the of course the ability to
have shared code possibly if you have an
existing web application that you want
to you know take import to a desktop
application there's a good chance that
you can reuse a lot of the UI and even
some of the backend code if you use if
you're using node and
Tron and the folks at github and people
who have contributed electron have
solved a number of complex problems that
make you know building and distributing
electronic applications a whole lot
easier so things like if you're used on
a desktop application a little
notification pops up at the top and says
the new versions available do you want
to you know restart them and run it now
that's kind of baked into electron you
can provide that same kind of experience
to any of your folks that are using your
applications
and the native you user-experience
extensions things like file open and
save and print and desktop notifications
trade notifications those are all you
know a common API inside electron that
you can invoke and whichever operating
system the desk the applications running
on your going to see the native browsers
are the native windows pop up for file
open and save or printers or whatever so
it creates a kind of a seamless
experience that people would expect but
why would we want to consider building
desktop applications there's there's a
lot of use cases a lot of scenarios
offline being one of them being able to
create an application that someone can
use disconnected from the internet and
if you want to have access to local
hardware like printers and devices and
be able to control those kind of things
like medical devices medical or you know
things out in the field if you need an
application that's running on premises
this was my use case the I used to work
for a SAS company where we had a in a
product that was all web-based but we
had this need to be able to integrate
with other people's systems to get their
data out of their system or synchronize
our data with theirs and we couldn't you
know we couldn't ask these companies to
open up their firewall and let us reach
in and get their data a synchronize we
needed an application that was running
on premises that could communicate with
our api's and so forth and to generate
you know do things like generate reports
generate the integrations and so forth
if you're building internal a lot of
business applications it might be a
little bit easier editing local files
having that local storage if you have an
idea that you want to create an
application for the App Store you can
monetize your application that way in
the in the apple or Windows app stores
kiosk applications like out in the
retail or in hospitals or manufacturing
or whatever where somebody goes up and
interacts with a machine to to get
something done it's a great option and
sometimes desktop is much much easier
from you know logistics and red tape and
so forth being able to just you know
maybe you're building an application and
there's four people that need to be able
to use this application inside your
company and getting this application
deployed and updated on an Internet is
really really hard problem to solve with
your IT now this strikes fear into the
heart of a lot of IT folks but maybe you
can build an application that just
solves that one problem you can hand
them a flash drive or you know give them
some files that allows them to run your
application and not have to go through
all the loopholes and you know the red
tape of getting it deployed to an
intranet server
and sometimes desktop applications still
just feel like the best kind of tool for
the job this is a big list of ideas that
I brainstormed and came up with one day
just looking at different desktop
applications I'm not gonna go through
them and read these all to you but just
to give you an idea of some of the
problems you might solve or you know
things opportunities you might have to
build your own desktop applications
now you probably have seen Adam Adam
used to be the golden child of editors
you know people you know that we're
using sublime you know Adam came on the
scene and you know took things by storm
most of you probably use slack at one
time or another or you love to hate
slack or you don't have some kind of
love-hate relationship with it but slack
is what caught my attention when I found
out that slack the desktop client is an
electron application that that just kind
of blew my mind it was like this is this
is a you know you know problems with
performance and memory usage and all
those things aside this is a really
nice-looking welded well-designed
you know easy to use application that is
essentially a web app running on your
desktop that's cool and then the new kid
on the block if you use Visual Studio
code it is an electron application and
when Visual Studio code came out my
first thought was I just assumed
Microsoft was using dotnet to build
their editor and I thought well how did
they solve the problems that I ran into
you know trying to build cross-platform
desktop apps and you know I started
poking around and trying to get more
information about it and I just was
shocked I was floored that Microsoft is
using these open source technologies and
it's not that it's JavaScript and you
know they're using this too and they've
had such it's it's a huge success I use
Visual Studio code all the time it is
the you know one of the best if not the
best JavaScript debugging tools and
editors out there
I've just been continue to be impressed
with this tool it is a new Microsoft
if you do anything with api's you may be
interested in postman it is a fantastic
API interaction tool or you can you know
create requests and send those off to an
API endpoint see the results that come
back you can save those requests and
replay them later if you build api's or
interact with api's in any way this is a
great tool to use and then most recently
getting github this desktop app they
have switched to using electron for
their desktop tools and it works really
well and then one of the most
interesting electron applications i've
run across is this social robot called
Gebo or jibu I forget how it's
pronounced but it's it's designed to be
not only like no Alexa or a Google home
or something like that but it's
interactive it's it's animated it spins
around and it's able to provide you know
emotion it's like a little animated
character sitting on your on your desk
and it's quite cool to interact with so
the screen itself is an electron
application and it can change and you
know create expressions as well as show
information and then the software that
you use to create your own extensions or
interactions or anything with this
little robot is an electron application
so now that we've talked about desktop
apps and examples of electron I want to
show you a little bit about how you get
started building with electron so the
first step really that you know before
this is you you need to have no js'
installed and it doesn't matter which
version of node you know any modern any
you know stable recent stable version of
node will work but once you have node
installed you have this command-line
utility npm that you can use to install
packages so you want to create a a
folder for your your project and run npm
install electron that's going to pull
down the binaries and other things that
you need and you'll need a couple of
files a javascript file an HTML file it
doesn't matter what they're named it's
just typically they're like main j s or
index j s or server.js
whatever you want to call it and then
like an index dot HTML you know whatever
your you want your main screen to be in
vote you know give you some vocabulary
of electron an electron application
starts its life cycle as a nodejs
process so when you open an electron
application it first fires up node under
the covers and node does some
bootstrapping and then it launches from
this main process one or even more what
what's called renderers renderers are
the the chrome side of things and it's
not the entire chrome browser it's just
chromium the UI rendering of HTML
so there's this under the covers node
uses chrome v8 JavaScript engine and so
does chromium so they're they're married
together in your main J's file that
doesn't like click the bootstrapping
that I mentioned this is typically what
you'll find as standard kind of code
require is similar to an imports or a
using statement that's how you bring in
external modules or local modules into
your nodejs application
so we're gonna require in electron and
off of that electron object we're going
to get grab the the app and browser
window and then the app object has a
number of you know life cycle events
that happen so similar to jQuery has a
document ready event you have this app
on ready event that means you know
electron and node have finished starting
up and the the environment is now ready
now you can go and do what you need to
do so in this ready event we're going to
create a new main window a new browser
window and we can set things like width
and height and there's also a whole lot
more you can do you can set positions
you can set minimum the maximum widths
and Heights you can make it movable or
resizable or not you can set that kiosk
mode so that it's full screen and
someone can only interact with that one
application and there's lots of other
options too
and then lastly we want to load in our
HTML file for render in that main
browser window
and a question I get a lot is well can
you know this this says load URL and I
load any URL and the answer is yes you
can point this to some external URL but
that there's a couple of issues with
that and I wouldn't you know you can do
that as a proof of concept but that's
something that you would not want to do
long term and I'll go into that a little
bit more later in your HTML file
just a hello world you can have
something you know very simple with a
title and a body and then from the
command line you can use electrons space
the whatever the javascript file is that
you've created and when you do that it
launches a browser window and creates
you know renders what you have in your
HTML and this interesting to note that
the title of the HTML page becomes the
title of the window and whatever is in
the body becomes what is rendered in the
window itself
but here is the really cool and awesome
thing about electron because electron
shares the v8 JavaScript engine with you
know from node with the browser with the
renderers you have access to far more
features and capabilities than just your
normal browser experience so anything
you can do with NPM or with node you can
do directly from your HTML you don't
like I made the incorrect assumption
when I first started building electronic
a shion's is that well how do I you know
there's got to be a web server here
somewhere you know I you know I've got
to create my own API and communicate
from HTML back to my my you know foe
server to get something done and that's
not the case at all anything you can do
in node you can do directly from within
your HTML so in this example I'm
requiring in you know inside my HTML the
the filesystem module which is part of
node that's how you can read and write
files and and do IO and I'm using that
to read the the home directory of the
person that's using the application
electron extends has its own set of
modules and api's that give you easy
access to things like this environment
variable home is correctly points to the
home directory of whatever operating
system their own so if they're running
this on Windows it's going to be under
you know the documents and you know
folder path and if you're running on Mac
it's going to be under the users home
you know path folder
and I'm gonna interact through all those
things and and and get a list the other
thing I wanted to point out in this
example is that you know again this is
modern es6 syntax you can use fat arrow
syntax you can use promises you can now
use async in a way you can use all those
things that are in the latest versions
of node and the eight so with the
electron version 2.0 that was just
released it's running under the covers
node eight point nine and chromium 61 do
you have you know as I mentioned before
your your this is what you're targeting
doesn't matter what's already installed
on the the person's computer who's using
the application this is what you you can
take advantage of another quick tip I
want to give you is that since it is
chromium there's a some things that you
can do like I had open the the dev tools
so when you build as you're building
your application maybe you want to
interact with it and use the the chrome
dev tools that you are you're probably
already familiar with so you can add
them you can launch your win your
application with the chrome dev dev
tools attached part of the same window
or detached in the separate window and
you can do things like as you might
expect
you can set breakpoints on your code and
step through and inspect variables and
do all the debugging things that you
would normally do using the chrome dev
tools now there are you may have heard
this before but there are two hard
problems in software development cache
and validation naming things and
off-by-one errors
well I submit to you that there are
actually for our problems and I don't
know what your experience is with like
in your development environment but you
know and the teams that I've worked on
it's really really important to have you
know the right animated gifts at your
your fingertips when you're doing you
know code reviews or if you're
interacting with your co-workers on
slack you got to be able to express
yourself correctly so I created an
electron application called a reactor
because in the past if he was just so so
bad if you tried to use giffy and slack
is like the worst right it was like so
bad it was almost awesome but not
awesome so this reactor application I
created solves this problem for me so I
can search you know for a particular
image and as I mouse over any of those
animated gifts it'll give me you know a
preview of what it looks like I think
well that one's that one's okay but I
don't think it really expresses how I
feel about my co-workers code that I'm
looking at so I search for Spock nope
and spot comes over
and yes that's what I want so I click
the button to copy it to my clipboard
paste it into slack or wherever I want
it and you know away we go and this is
probably the best application I've
created in my career
so in two further kind of go along with
the electron architecture and the things
that are available to you remember we
talked about there being a process and
which is your nodejs
application part of your application
there's a rent there's renderers you can
have more than or or you know one or
more and then there's some api's that
are common to both so in the process
what's available to you is app app was
like we showed was have lifecycle events
you can also parse command-line
arguments so if you want to set your
electron application to be the default
application for a particular extension
you can you can do that and you can
parse whatever is passed along the
command line to open those files use app
to figure out what are the system and
user paths IPC is inter-process
communications this is how you
communicate between the renderer and the
main process is through messages so
there's an IPC for the the process
there's an IPC module for the renderer
and you can use those kind of like a
publish and subscribe mechanism where
you can say this is the name of the
channel I want to publish this on and
here's the message you've got native
dialogues so like the file open save and
info and error messages those things
that I mentioned before you've got a
common menu API so as you describe what
your menus items are and what what is
going to show up across the top of your
your application you've got this one
interface where you can build up your
menus programmatically and it'll render
it correctly on whichever operating
system it's running on he's on you've
also got a power monitor module where
you can detect not only you know is is
the
Desktop that I'm running on is it
connected to power or is it running on
battery but you also get events like
it's going into hybrid 8 or the the lid
has been closed and you know I'm
shutting down or whatever you can just
respond to those events and like close
connections to others you know to files
or external sources so that you can
cleanly you know respond to those kinds
of events
there's the tray notification and then
on the menthe renderer side of things
you've got IPC again there's this
special version of IPC called remote
which is almost like a shortcut to
sending a command and in having the main
process do some work for you there's a
special HTML tag called web frame now
this this goes back to the question
earlier about can I load external
content into my electron application and
you can you can you can load in it an
external app but web frame the problem
is security if you just arbitrarily load
in content from an external source you
could be opening up a desktop
application to security issues and an
electron application is not sandbox
anything you can do whatever the user
has the ability to do like you know read
and write files or change the registry
or you know whatever the privileges are
your electron application can do that so
to prevent external content from being
malicious and doing damage you can bring
that content in in a web frame and that
web frame is sandboxed and does not have
access to any of the nodejs and npm
modules and all those kinds of things
that could do damage
modules that are available to both
you've got a clipboard which I was using
in my demo to you know copy the URL for
the animated gif to the clipboard you
can do text and you know multimedia type
things there's a built in crash reporter
so when your application crashes you can
give it an end point for you to you know
post some data about that crash back to
one of your own servers there's a native
image module so you can deal with
monitor resolutions DPI's so you can
have alternatives to you know normal DPI
images that you want to use in your
application this this is typical for
like tray icons desktop icons or other
types of images there's a screen module
that allows you to not only enumerate
the displays that are connected to a
desktop but but also has events like you
know win a win a laptop or a screen is
connected you can know the resolutions
or those screens you can launch your
application you know and take advantage
of multiple screens so forth and then
there's the all-important shell which
you can won't use to launch other
external applications or to launch you
know code that you might compile and
ship with your application or to you
know beep someone's computer speaker the
all-important PC speaker beep
the deploying electron there's there's
like some stages of complexity and how
you might approach this so at the at the
very first phase like if you're doing a
proof-of-concept or if you're creating
something that just a handful of people
are going to use you can take the
binaries for the electron application
that are made available for every
operating system so you can take the
32-bit or 64-bit binaries of Windows or
Mac and for Linux and then you can take
your JavaScript and HTML files and CSS
that you've created and just you know
bundle those together you know in the
same folder and hand that to someone and
they can run your the electron
executable and run your application it's
it's really easy the next step is to
take all the code that you created and
compile this to a an application on
Windows this looks like an executable
with a bunch of DLLs and some other
things so it's typical what you would
which you would find when you're
building an application on the Mac it
creates a an app file so it looks you
know to the user it looks like a single
location looks like a single file that
they can double click on and run you can
take that a step further and build an
installer for your application and
there's installers that you can you can
have for each operating system and then
there's the mechanisms for adding
automatic updates so you can set up a
service that your application can point
to that will you know when when the
application is running it'll
periodically you know hit an end point
on that server or see if there's an
update available bring it down and and
note and notify internally that an
updates available and then you can do
whatever you want you can prompt the
user to restart to apply that update or
you can just apply the next time the
application is run however you want to
do so it recommended tools in the tool
box
there's electron debug which allows
I know I don't know if this is even
necessary anymore but used to when you
build an electron application if you
want to give someone the ability to hit
f12 or whatever the command shift I
whatever the keyboard shortcuts are for
bringing up the dev tools in in your
application if you use electron debug
you give your users the ability to do
that I think that's I think that's built
in now but electron debug gives you some
some other things around you know it
makes a little bit easier as you're
building your application the electron
reload is another developer a nice tool
to have kind of like hot reloading when
you're building a web application you
know typically before electron reload
came along you build your electron
application you launch it you notice
something it needs to be fixed now you
got to close it and restart it again
make that change well electron reload it
will detect any HTML JavaScript or CSS
changes and will automatically
essentially refresh or restart your your
web interface so that you can
immediately see those changes and keep
on iterating on your application without
having to restart it electron packager
is guts you know a number of great tools
to create the executables from your
application builder is what takes that
another step further increased
installers for your application electron
updater you know there's there's update
capabilities built into electron but
electron updater makes it just even more
easy to create those those install and
update events and then if you do if you
prefer like I've in the past I've used
mocha quite a bit for doing testing and
unit tests and behavior tests in my
application electron mocha or mocha by
itself does not is not aware of all the
api's that are available to electron so
electron mocha is like a drop-in
replacement of mocha that does
understand the the api's that are
available so that you can use those
under your tests
there's some other tools that that
github has created dev Tron is a Chrome
extension that you can add to your
project and it'll do things like give
you insight into the IPC messages that
are going back and forth between your
renderers in the main process it can
give it's got some linting capabilities
they'll tell you if you've done
something you know prescriptively wrong
or haven't included something in your
application that they recommend that you
do
there's also spectrin which is a whole
UI testing framework is built on chrome
driver and web driver that you can build
UI tests or your lecture on applications
and then getting started with electron
there are a number of really good
boilerplate projects out there my
recommendation though I'll give these to
you there's electron bullet boilerplate
which is kind of front-end agnostic it's
just plain HTML but it gives you a lot
of tools that help you to build you know
create executables and create installers
for your application and then there's a
reactor plate I'm sure there's an Euler
and view by now if you you know if those
are your front-end tools of choice but I
will say that I've done a number of
workshops with electron and helped a lot
of folks guilt you know and what helped
me the most when I got started with
electron is to build an electron
application from scratch without using a
boilerplate once I understood
although you know all the work that goes
into building like this infrastructure
beyond just a HelloWorld application
then I knew what the boiler plates were
doing for me and I you know better
understood the benefits of using a
boiler plate whereas before when I tried
to start with a boiler plate I didn't
know what part I was having issues with
what was an electron or was it the
boiler plate applicate you know code
that was trying to be helpful
another great place to start or another
option that that you may want to
consider is this project called electron
pre-built compile it is a drop-in
replacement for the electron executable
it was built by one of the core original
core members of the electron team and
this executable has built into it
babel typescript and graph QL it
understands a lot of things natively
things like react less Jade View
components these things that would
normally require you to set up some kind
of translation in your electron
application this knows all these kinds
of things right out of the box so you
don't have to have that that build step
to do the transpiration you can just
ship your application with typescript or
with graph QL capabilities or with react
and it will you know handle those those
types of components and features on the
fly
building an electron application you can
use whatever front-end technologies
you're most comfortable with if you want
to use just plain HTML Javascript and
maybe some jQuery there's no shame in
doing that this is this is an
application that I created it took me
about two weeks to do it and most of
that was booked all the backend stuff
for for the reports this is just HTML
Javascript some little bit of jQuery and
I think I use bootstrap as my CSS Styles
and you know it looks kind of like a web
application but it looks looks it gets
the job done
it looks pretty nice I was pretty happy
with it
cuz we're pretty happy with it there's a
CSS framework called a photon kit that
makes your applications look even less
web like and more native currently it's
just for mac UI i think the long term
goal is to add a bunch of UI elements to
make it look like a Windows app when
it's running on Windows and make it look
like a Linux app when it's running on
Linux so right now if you use photon and
you run your application on Windows it
just looks like a really beautiful Mac
app running on Windows I don't have a
problem on that so this is an
application that I created using that
photon kit that made it look more you
know Mac native and I was really pleased
with the results and how it behaved how
it looked all the all the windows all
the elements and styling the icons that
it provides it's it was pretty nice
so some tips on building electronic
Asians when you're using a browser and
you mouse over a link or something you
can click on especially if you're on a
Mac you get this little cartoon hand
character you know that points at the
thing that you can click on well that's
that's fine for web apps but that's
typically not what people expect to have
how their desktop apps behave so you
know it's it's a little thing but turn
you know set the CSS so that's always
using the default cursor for everything
you know every kind of element if you
have multiple windows in your
application and someone goes to close a
window if there's a chance that they may
want to see that window again
well don't close it just hide it and
then next time they go to see that
window you can instantly you know
display that instead of the few
milliseconds that could take to recreate
that window and then rerender it and
bring it up on the screen if you have
background work that you're doing such
as going and fetching you know stuff
from api's building files interacting
with files going sketching stuff from a
database any of those kinds of things
you know this is kind of like the poor
man's multitasking or multi-threading is
you want to do that work on a main
thread or you could do that work on on
an invisible window some folks have have
gone that route so you can use IPC to
send a message to the main thread to say
look go do this thing like open up a
file dialog and allow someone to save a
file and you send that message to the
main main process the main process does
whatever it needs to do and sends a
message back to your renderer to say I'm
done or this was the result or whatever
that you can then display to the user
and this gives you know allows your
application to continue to be responsive
and
you know nice to use while that work is
being done behind the scenes local
storage is typical to any desktop
application is you need to be able to
you know keep track of state keep track
of files do do things that and remember
things as your application is closed and
reopened typically when on desktop
applications you want to you know you
want the size of your window to be the
way you want it to be you want it to you
know be positioned on the right spot on
the desktop and when you close it and
reopen it you expect your application to
be in that same spot again and to be the
same size again and you can do that just
by capturing an event in the main
process reading those X Y coordinates
and the size of the window and storing
that locally and then just reading that
back up in the next time the application
launches so things like that plus you
know any kinds of files that you you
know work with locally the first
approach is just read and write JSON
files you know you got JSON data that
you're creating inside your application
from JavaScript you can just read read
and write those to the user to the
applications directory and use something
like FS jetpack or there's another one
called FS extra that's promise promise
if I'd and it's like a you know you know
the FS module that come the filesystem
module that comes with node but with a
lot more things attached to it it makes
it easier to read and write JSON
to take that a step further if you need
like a database type storage in your
application any DB is a great start it
under the covers it's just reading and
writing JSON files but the API is kind
of like a subset of DB so you can
query it you can you know you know store
records you know records at a time and
then another step even further than that
is an application called pouch DB that
is the entire couch DB API replicated in
JavaScript so that you can not only
interact with it just as you would with
with cow like you would with couch TV it
has synchronization capability so if you
want one of those offline type scenarios
where you want to use your application
in the field and then when they come
back to the office or you know have cell
phone you know access again they can
synchronize the pouch DB app can
synchronize with a couch TV server
if you're running internally and you
know in your organization and want to
use things like relational databases
absolutely anything you can do with NPM
any kind of module that's available on
NPM you can use in your electron
applications so Syria if you use sequel
server post Gray's my sequel oracle DB
messaging systems RabbitMQ 0m you
literally there's you know hundreds of
thousands of modules that are available
on the NPM you can use those in your
electronic application to do just about
anything you want
from here this is the one-stop shop for
everything electron if you search
essentially go to Google and search for
awesome electron you're gonna land on
this repo and it's the exhaustive list
of all articles videos tutorials sample
applications other open source of
projects tons and tons of things to
point you to building and helping you
build your electron application if you
have access to plural site J Trent
electron fundamentals is fantastic it's
the course I wish I had created if I
were a Pluralsight author and highly
recommend that there's there's also a
Pluralsight course that Rob Connery
created on electron called the electron
playbook that's also really good it's
kind of his it's not like an
introduction to electron it's more like
here are the things I've learned to do
with electron and you know it's kind of
like tips and tricks from the master and
then the documentation at electron dot
atom to i/o is really really good
there's some tutorials and how to's and
you know they'll step you through
getting your your first application up
and running I don't have this on the
list but there's
in my github repo I have an electron
workshop that I've done several times
all the exercises and the instructions
for doing that workshop are in an
electron workshop repo under if you just
search for go to github slash forever
and eek you can find that that may be a
good good way to get started and then
the slack community for electron is
really active or super helpful if you
have any questions you run into any kind
of issues you can post them there and
expect to get some friendly responses
last thing I want to leave you with is
you don't need permission to be awesome
this is I I really really believe that
those of us in technology have a unique
opportunity to impact our community and
our world and just be very powerful in
significant ways the technologies that
you're learning about here at this
conference the things that you geek out
about I want you to keep in perspective
that you have the ability to make a huge
impact on the people that you work with
the people all around the world
technology is awesome and I encourage
you to take the things that you're
learning and that you go and be awesome
thank you again shameless plug if you
enjoyed some of my silly artwork I have
a leadership talk at 3 o'clock that's
mostly all humor that's mostly all silly
stuff and it's all hand drawn so I would
love for you to come to that talk in
this room at 3 o'clock is there there
got a few more minutes are there any
questions I can answer yes
you
so their concerns about security there
are security concerns that I think the
question that you're asking is is there
a concern about having node and you know
running on the desktop and what note is
capable of doing so that's that concern
is really the concern of any desktop
application any desktop application it's
whatever the security context is of the
user that's running that application
that application can do anything that
that user can do so if that user has
access to do damage the registry or to
access files on a network sure you're
you got to limit your risk there but the
security question that I typically get
is I want to protect the the
intellectual property of my application
you know how do I do that you know if I
if I ship an application you know in its
HTML and JavaScript people are going to
know what's going on and they can you
know so the way I've seen companies
address that is building some kind of
you know so there's ways that you can
extend node that aren't just JavaScript
you can write C you know if you got C
libraries you can you know take your
intellectual property and create a C
library of those things and use that
from in your application I know there
was one applet one company who used
Haskell they took all their links
intellectual property and because they
were they were just super into using
Haskell and Haskell is cross-platform
they just compiled all their
intellectual property code into Haskell
dll's and then invoke those from from
within their application right I mean
you can you can create a basically a
bundled file a bundled you know it's
essentially a zip file it doesn't you
know it doesn't have a zip file
extension but if you compress your
application and do go that route it's
all in there as a REIT as a resource
file but somebody knows what they're
doing I can just open that up and in in
parse it
any other question yes performance
issues with v8 yeah so a common concern
for electronic applications is
performance with v8 and chrome using
memory and using you know a lot of
resources on the computer yeah there's a
there's a meme going around with you
know hey what would you do with an
eighteen Cormack run to two electron at
the same time um I mean it is true there
are things I think mistakes were made
and things got hurt you know with
electron especially like the slack app
that gets a lot of a bad rap for being a
resource hog but it's some of that has
to do with how many slack communities
you're connected to and how much stuff
it's having to do in the background to
to you know keep all those communities
up to date and so forth um I don't have
a real good answer I mean there's a
there's the base application that if you
run a hello world it's not it's not that
large you know it's like three four
hundred K you know plus some resources
and depending on how many browser
windows you create it's gonna you know
each one of those windows is going to
eat into another chunk of memory but in
my experience the applications I've
created have been fairly simple and have
not had any performance issues or caused
anyone you know to scream at me you know
so I think it's
yes
okay so the recommended development
environment for electron is that I would
recommend is Visual Studio code Visual
Studio code is not only a great
JavaScript debugger but it has some
knowledge of electronic a shion's built
into it
so like when you go to debug an
application you have a number of choices
of is this a a web app is this an ojs
application excuse me is this an
electron application you can choose
electron and it knows how to attach to
the electron process it knows how to you
know give you the capabilities of
stepping through your code and so forth
so the combination really is elect
Visual Studio code for debugging the
process side of things the main process
and then you can use the chrome dev
tools that are built built into v8 and
chrome to debug and step through your
front-end is sort of speak code thus
that's the two-headed thing for
development
does that answer your question I'm sure
you could use other tools you know like
some folks are really keen on using
webstorm or something like that you know
sure you can you can use node to attach
you can attach that process our even
Visual Studio
Visual Studio code is what I would
recommend
all right thank you you've been awesome
go go and be awesome